The joe rogan experience.
Oh Geez.
Let me say so most,
there's another,
that whole society that he hasn't touched in on you that I know he knows about.
And that's the Aba Qua society.
WHATSAPP.
A common,
that's a complete,
that's the,
that's the Brotherhood of men and Cuba.
You'll see it.
So as you see an APP,
McGuire,
you know you're dealing with them.
I don't talk to them that they don't giggle.
They don't.
What does that mean?
Like what it,
man,
I fuck with you.
A couple of years ago you were living in Colorado and I saw a kid with a balloon
and I call you balloons and [inaudible] around me and Eddie.
You come up to a number call and call him his nickname.
You got a different situation.
He'll pull you aside and go,
I don't know you and don't you ever fucking call me that outside the circle
again.
And when they get mad at you,
okay to prove their manhood,
they,
they beat you,
throw you on the floor,
pull your pants down and slice your ass with a straight razor.
That's worse than fucking a man.
One did that.
The two or three people at my mother's wake guy couldn't come in because one,
it's sliced as asked and I don't know.
This guy took me to baseball games.
One,
get the fuck out.
He stand.
That's the thing that only pussy.
They can't be in a room if another man is gay in the room.
Wow.
Oh yeah.
Guess what Y'all Romero told me it's sold.
Dissolved.
Now that there's gay men and Habaqois 50 years ago,
bro,
Bro,
some people would call that advanced Joey.
That's progress.
What's that?
Now there's game.
Well,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
no.
Look,
look at the surprise.
They had the gay man,
but 50 years ago when I went to Albert quarters were in the room.
You had to be on your best behavior.
They don't speak Spanish.
[inaudible]
they have their own line.
They have their own language.
Oh,
and I know it.
I know it.
They have their own language,
their own language in Spanish.
It's a,
it's like a Patois.
It's like a Patois.
It's based on African Monina.
I said,
hey,
when I call you Monina,
that's my brother and that thing.
What's the Organization of this group?
I mean,
is it is,
it shows the long shore man.
There's a matter of Cuba.
They don't even eat pussy.
That's such a man.
But they add,
they could fuck other men and other men could suck.
They're big.
They're big in prison systems.
Prager system.
They can fuck other men.
Oh yeah,
I could.
I could pick you out and go,
Joe,
you're no longer Joe.
You're Josephine.
We'll get a wig and put lipstick on by the away and I'll fuck you in the ass and
you're going to suck my dick.
Don't you ever fucking think you're gonna fucking kiss me and touch me?
And they'd beat you.
You can shut up.
You fucking whore.
You can fuck somebody else,
but you can't be fucking man every fuck by another man.
That's a lot.
But if a man wants to shuck it,
next,
let them,
so I remember one night he used to tell him,
I guys suck my Dick one time when ice cubes in his mouth.
It was tremendous.
What fucking talking about?
Well,
that was the fourth grade I was surrounded with.
You say hello a certain way?
Yeah.
What?
Like,
I'll show you a knob.
Quad video.
How do you spell it?
Okay.
Hey B.
You K you a,
here it is.
Hey,
[inaudible].
What does the strato pulling up?
There's a bunch of,
yeah,
here on Youtube.
I'll show you the dance one is the one.
You have to see how they dance,
how they move about quite you rule,
bull,
whatever.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
This is the second one.
Good on that second one,
hour long.
And so these are just serious dudes.
Habaqois and then put in y o r u.
B a and let me tell it.
We'll see what comes up.
It's also African base also.
Africa has a musical elements right there.
Right there.
There you go.
Okay.
Let me show you what an Abbott choirs and they're all dressed in white.
They're all dressed in white.
It's still dressed in white.
No women allowed.
No nothing.
The place.
Some of this Jamie said,
we can hear it.
No women.
Nah,
though there's woman woman's second.
A woman there,
we'll,
we'll dance every day.
Yeah.
So you see the woman on the right?
I'll see how the guy shows up.
That's an albacore look at this fucking beauty.
Yeah.
The colors are white and red.
Right?
You will see red.
That's the guy.
The,
the,
the
like the tin man from the wizard of Oz there.
The,
you know,
just saying that could get a break there to salute with your elbows.
Hit it back,
get a bad you,
you,
you could suffer.
Making fun of making fun of it.
Wow.
If I see him,
that's how I do it.
This dog let me know.
But
you touch elbows,
touch elbows.
Wow.
And now there's actually gay men in there now.
It's diluted so much.
Ah,
it's been diluted over the years.
But when,
when I met Juan and Leo,
they would two ob applause.
Uh,
but Taco tico or Latin band,
not the cube,
not the Congo,
the singer.
He was up quality.
So if you were a quad,
you just,
there was a code,
the way you behave.
Very badly.
Code.
I come over here,
there's a gay man and he I call you out of the room like,
oh do me a favor,
get that mother fucker out of the room.
Or if not,
you can't talk to them.
You can't approach him a certain way.
Cuba experienced a lot of progressive ideology.
Like is it,
have they changed the way it's very progressive now.
What's caused this cause they really do a rebel progress changing things.
Yeah,
but their progress.
I mean there are so isolated,
they didn't have the Internet right?
They don't have the Internet.
No.
I think certain places and they're getting it now.
I think certain places,
yeah you can get it here and there.
It's not great.
It's frustrating when you go there cause he can't.
What's,
what's Nice is you go to Havana and you kind of disengage from modern
technology.
I love it.
I mean you couldn't live there cause he can't really do business there.
Right.
But you just kind of disengage from.
And is it easy to travel there now as far as like flights from America?
Just legal like a motherfucker
fucking hilarious.
I remember when I was a kid,
like if you had a Cuban cigar,
it was like a big deal.
I don't tell anybody we got Cubans.
Well that's still,
that's still illegal.
No,
it's the embargo.
The embargo is still exists.
Yeah,
but you could have some cigars.
You're allowed to have some Cuban cigars.
Right.
You ever like,
see if you,
uh,
what does the amount of,
I think you're allowed to have like 10.
You can't bring them back.
Yeah.
You can't sell them here.
Or if you can sell them here,
you can't sell a lot.
Something like that.
And I'm happy he wrote this book because I knew the story was out that job.
Like we haven't even touched.
I'm like,
I was raised by Omega seven guy.
Like he grew up with my father.
So I told Joey when I first met him,
and I was sort of almost done with this book.
I said,
when you read it,
you're going to need to sit down.
Because for a guy like him,
he knew a lot.
And I knew he would come across names that he knew,
but there's no way you could have been part of this and known the whole thing.
Right,
right.
So you,
you like,
you knew who thought it was.
You knew he was a bad guy.
He didn't know [inaudible] was a professional assassin for Omega seven.
I knew thought they killed my mother warned me and my mother used to go,
when he picks you up at school,
please don't get in the car with him cause he's going to get shot one day and I
don't want to enter people new battle.
And they knew some things about him but they didn't know,
don't want who was part of it.
They thought they knew the whole story.
But there's no way you could've,
you couldn't done it all.
It,
it blew my fucking mind.
I went to a dance with my daughter and I came home and the book was waiting for
me,
you know,
Amazon and drops it off in front of your house.
And they had ripped it and there was other kids and other moms with my wife and
I don't like did was put it in my office and when I opened it I saw a.
Dot.
D and Munchie and my fucking knee dropped like it had hit me.
He kept texting me as you were reading at 12 o'clock at night and I go,
you have no,
but I didn't know that this guy used to go every six months and his wife was
tight.
You know the story I told you about,
my mom would play cards and then I would put tidy whities on and dance for the
women to be shots of Tequila and make me dance.
Neda was in that book.
Nina is in that book.
When my mother died,
I gave me to my dog.
I couldn't take that dog.
So I used to go to Nina's house on 51st street and cry in the dog house.
Like this was my dog.
So as soon as I saw Tati,
I knew he was onto something because Dottie was my father's friend and he was a
type of guy that would come visit me every week just because he was my fault,
his friend,
and give me 50 bucks and take me to the city.
You get haircuts with his claim to fame was in the seventh grade.
My mother told him,
I don't know what I'm gonna do with him.
He's got some fucking girlfriend.
He won't even talk to me.
This guy came to my house and gave me a capsule and right in front of me,
he filled it up with coke and he goes,
let me tell you something.
Seventh grade,
seventh grade,
he goes,
next time this girl comes over,
you sprinkled his coke on a pussy and you lick it.
And I'm like,
I didn't even like a pussy that I hadn't touched that outside the genes,
that coat capsule was in my draw for like a year,
like in the back of my nightstand.
Right.
I didn't,
you know,
I wasn't out.
It wasn't a driving,
nothing.
At one night,
my mom came home with three cocktails,
and then she's like,
I got fucking news today from Tophi that he gave you cocaine.
What the fuck is,
I got some my draw it and use it.
She fucking smack me.
She goes,
don't you have a fucking take drugs and I,
she wasn't dead it,
Eh,
you know what I'm saying?
Then she went and did the blast,
but that guy,
when I was in the [inaudible],
Greg gave me a capsule of coke.
Wow.
And said,
put it on a bus.
You drive a four pack.
Like that's how good he was.
Okay.